xiin ping over in China has reportedly
purged 500,000 CCP officials in just the
year
2023 and this is being reported as a
horrible thing but it should be clear
when they say he purged these officials
they're not talking entirely about
stalinesque Mass executions there have
been some party members who have gone
missing at least for periods of time and
but broad when they're talking about
500,000 people purged from the Communist
Party they talking about people who were
fired and brought up on charges and and
punished for for corruption uh this
is call me crazy I don't want to seem
like I'm a she apologist here or like
I'm Pro but isn't that good isn't it
good to get rid of and punish not not
like get rid of but you know like fire
and punish the corrupt people in your
government would shouldn't we be doing
that wouldn't that be good if we if we
also did that we we never do that no one
who engages in corruption in our
government gets in trouble Republicans
get in trouble for not engaging in
corruption Democrats engage in
widespread corruption the president of
the United States along with his son and
his brother shook down leaders around
the world for millions and millions of
dollars they we we have copies of the
checks of the payments from the bagman
to the big guy up top the Oval Office
occupant Joe Biden himself and it
doesn't matter doesn't matter whatsoever
and and forget about the electeds for
second what about all the bureaucrats we
always are complaining about the Deep
State the administrative State well what
we need to do is Purge the Deep State
and the administrative State not in the
Stalin way but not totally dissimilar
from the xiin Ping way we need to fire
them get them out of their positions of
power and if they've committed crimes we
need to try them for those
crimes the federal bureaucracy is
hundreds of it's millions of people
actually depends on exactly how you
count it but it could be up to two
million people most presidents who come
into office are able to swap out four to
5,000 people in the bureaucracy in order
to have anything even resembling
meaningful change you would have to swap
out 40 to 50,000 at least so I look at
she here and I think well I don't like
communism I'm not rooting for America's
adversary Over America I'd like America
to be really strong too but one way to
be strong is when we see our adversaries
do things that are effective and that
are helping their countries maybe we
ought to learn that lesson
too now if we're we're going to engage
in any kind of serious political action
we're going to want our bodies to be
feeling good which is why we're going to
want to check out good ranchers right
now go to goodranchers.com use promo
code nolles there's a lot at stake this
November so don't be chicken and shop at
the grocery store like usual instead
head on over to good ranchers no that's
not a pun that's just a great place good
ranchers this is my only problem with
being on the road I like being on the
road I'm in a fun location right now but
it means I eat less good ranchers
because it's all in my freezer at home
and sweet little Lisa can only well she
can only make it four or five nights a
week sometimes for breakfast too their
Black Friday your way sale is live it's
something you don't want to miss they've
got great meat puns they've got even
better meat this November you get to
pick your favorite meat to get free for
a year pick a year of free steak salmon
chicken or bacon when you subscribe to
any box right now man that is crazy it's
a crazy deal I'm I'm reading this for
the first time now that's outrageous
better yet when you Subs subribe to any
box on goodranchers.com you not only get
a free gift of meat worth up to 480
bucks but you also get up to $15 off
with code nolles K wle they got the best
meet out there you're going to get a
year of free meet 15 bucks off free
shipping with code nlls it totally sells
itself it's the number one place in
America to get all your meat and seafood
by the way and chicken and pork and all
of it goodranchers.com right now use
code nolles K
wle speaking of purges democrats for
years now have been talking about
packing the Supreme Court and they want
to pack the Supreme Court because the
court has generally
ruled in favor of conservatives on at
least a handful of important cases not
all the important cases the Supreme
Court with the support of allegedly
conservative Justice Gorsuch
enshrined into civil rights law that's
not very conservative the Supreme Court
redefined marriage now of course that
was before some of the before all of the
Trump got there but still there were
conservatives on the court they
redefined marriage in oera fell they
ratified Obamacare which was completely
unconstitutional they've done all sorts
of things but they've also overruled
roie Wade they've also ruled in favor of
the Second Amendment they so they've
done things that the Democrats don't
like and the Democrats have said okay
we're going to pack the Supreme Court
but that's politically unpopular because
it it seems as though Democrats are
upending our system of government and
the moderate Democrats and The
Independents and the kind of just
fashionable liberals they don't like
that that doesn't pull very well or play
well in Peoria so the Democrats have a
new strategy they're going to do reverse
Court packing I've got to thank Ken
kukowski over at Breitbart for that
phrase uh in a a recent write up
yesterday or the day before uh he
pointed out that reverse Court packing
will have much the same effect as
regular Court packing but it will be
more U acceptable to the public and what
is reverse Court packing reverse Court
packing when the Democrats go in and try
to get the conservative judges to recuse
themselves from a bunch of cases or
ideally to
resign and how are they going to do that
they're going to say that uh Clarence
Thomas went on vacation once and he
didn't pick up his breakfast tab the
host of a conference picked up the
breakfast Tab and so that's a bribe and
even if Clarence Thomas has never ruled
on any cases that really pertain to
these people it's just a it's it's
bribery it's
corruption Joe Biden is meanwhile just
collecting checks Handover fist millions
of dollars from China from Ukraine from
all over the world no no no that's not
forget about that pay no attention to
the man behind the curtain Clarence
Thomas he went to a summer camp once and
so he's got to resign from the Supreme
Court they're doing it to AO too how are
they going to go after him they're going
to go after Leonard Leo so Leonard leer
is the head of the Federalist Society
Federalist Society very important
conservative legal organization which
provided a lot of the judges during the
Trump Administration and it's it's
important to the conservative legal
ecosystem so Senate Democrats demems on
the Senate Judiciary Committee have
decided to subpoena Leonard Leo and
others even though Leo's attorneys are
saying you have no right to subpoena me
I'm a private citizen you you're not
charging me with a crime you have
there's no reason for you to subpoena me
a private citizen and you certainly have
no right to
subpoena Clarence Thomas or or Sam Alita
because to do so to say that the the US
Congress has some ultimate
oversite rights over the Supreme Court
is to say that the Supreme Court is
subservient to the Congress which is not
true we have three branches of
government and we have a separation of
powers we have checks and balances so
it's just completely Preposterous but
what else are they going to do this is
Dick Durban and Sheldon White House the
two Democrats who are demanding all of
these records because they think if they
can get Leo then Leo will probably go to
some of these conferences and different
nefarious back room smoke fil room kind
of things with with conservative judges
and then they'll be able to force them
to resign which will be more effective
at tilting the court in favor of
Democrats than uh packing it which is
unpopular so there's more than one way
to skin a cat Democrats are very clever
with these kinds of tactics
unfortunately if it starts to look like
this is going to work we're going to
have to do the same thing to them I
don't want to I don't want to go digging
through Elena kagan's trash can I don't
want to go hire a private eye to follow
Sonia Soto my or around I don't want to
have republicans in Congress subpoena
private citizens who one time had lunch
with any of the liberal judges but we
will have to do that
because such a thing would not be
immoral it would be somewhat Reckless to
our political system when the Democrats
initiate this kind of action but it
wouldn't be immoral it would be
perfectly just it just wouldn't wouldn't
really have a place in our system but
but that kind of retaliation would be
just and not to retaliate in that way
would be to concede the political order
to the libs which would be very very
unjust so they want to go down this road
it looks like they've come to their
senses on actually packing the Supreme
Court for positively packing the Supreme
Court so now they're going to try to
negatively pack the Supreme Court and
we're going to have to hit them if they
do it to us there's there's no way out
of that the only way out is through man
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey hey before you go ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nlls podcast
we'll see you next time